bro that was Snoop
[__] with it it's greatest in my life
[Music]
Gary if you have a love chopping up with
you man same my God we're very similar a
lot of ways like when I look at your
crew and I look at like this is it
like this is it because we love the game
gee put your hands in the air drinks in
your cup if you don't give a [__]
where's he go
are we gonna hear it
you know it's crazy the more I gave
thought I think we go in studio let's
just get our schedules lined up let's
film the [__] out of it yeah do a proper
three four minute trailer that it's like
real [__] yeah and [__] put it out
it'll [__] kill I think we're gonna
wrap up here with um something that
we've been in the lab with for a while
oh
they said oh like garyvee for the rap
you do got the rap voice though I can't
even front video voice is special
thank you my dude the Snoop v-friends
collab is happening
yes sir
d-o-g friends is going double GP GPS
good [__] fire thank you this was the
last Monday morning of your life could
you imagine when we filmed this theory
that if I told you eight years from now
would you complain about it would be a
song
I just don't get the mentality of being
head down sad on a Monday morning I'm
Gonna Make You Saturday Monday morning
that's what I want to do every morning
that's what I want from you please take
a step back and think about how awesome
it actually is
put your hands in the air drinks in your
cup if you don't give a [__] you tell 17
year old me this is happening
I was there today this [__] came
out like I'm 47 I was in high school all
my friends that I love in hip-hop
wearing like [__] starter jackets and
all that [__] and this [__]
showed up on that album and everybody's
like what I mean when this album dropped
my high school shut down you're gonna
change every game you go into my guy you
haven't even started it's momentum
builds momentum you know
you start getting more audacious
as you build I'm aware
wait a minute
people that work win
this man's a [__] living legend
sitting here doing takes no like and I'm
doing the same they know I'm doing the
same [__] one in the morning all these
kids want to be like someone and they
don't want to put in half the workers
you're working you're either work or you
don't
anyway
that's it
foreign